we have an update on a story from
Alabama we've been covering all week a
suspect in a mall shooting is in custody
but local leaders are still pushing for
more information on a police shooting at
the scene a police officer killed EJ
Bradford jr. during Thanksgiving night
apparently thinking he had fired gun
shots at the mall well the actual
suspect Aaron Brown was arrested in
Georgia after a manhunt that lasted
nearly a week mark Strassmann is in
Hoover Alabama that's just south of
Birmingham continuing to follow the
story mark good morning good morning
Hoover's mayor says the city is
cooperating with state investigators but
some city leaders want to take it a step
further and release all the information
and video from the night of the shooting
to help set the story straight and ease
tensions here
investigators say 20 year old Aaron
Brown is the gunman who started the
shooting at an Alabama shopping mall on
Thanksgiving night
US Marshals acting on tips arrested him
at this home near Atlanta on Thursday
we've done this vigil tonight in
memories of mr. a junior overnight
crowds gathered at a city park in
Birmingham to remember EJ Bradford jr.
the 21 year old was shot and killed by a
Hoover police officer responding to
reports of gunfire inside the river
chase Galleria Mall the officer believed
Bradford was the gunman investigators
say Bradford was armed but had a
concealed weapons permit and never fired
his gun he said a man now no room April
Pipkins is Bradford's mother
Bradford's family is urging
investigators to release evidence about
the shooting including video from the
officers body camera they have our love
they have our prayers
Hoover City Councilman Derrick Murphy
said the city would consider releasing
the information if state investigators
refused in the event we don't receive
their information by Monday at noon the
chief will decide whether to release
delivering the information on his own
one local minister
said the information would help calm
days of protests by supporters of
Bradford's family through transparency
the clarity and through honesty we can
make this a scar that can heal state
investigators say any evidence released
prematurely could hurt their ongoing
review of what happened but Bradford's
family is growing impatient they bury
their son tomorrow Noora mark thank you